>> Materials supplied by
Microsoft Corporation may be
used for internal review,
analysis, or research only.
Any editing, reproduction,
publication, rebroadcast,
public showing, Internet or
public display is forbidden
and may violate copyright law.
>> Hi, everyone.
Thank you for coming.
Today, we're going to have
Professor Torsten Hoefler
present some of his work.
So, Torsten has been
a professor at UIUC,
and now, he's a professor
at ETH Zurich.
He is visiting the Quantum group
here in Microsoft,
and he works primarily on
parallel computing performance,
and he's published
over 200 papers,
which is quite impressive.
Donald had pointed me to Torsten
and I haven't been
aware of his work,
so it sounds very interesting.
So I'm looking
forward to learning
about his work today. Thank you.
>> Very good. Thank
you very much.
Yes, I'm from ETH,
and I've been here two months,
and this is actually today
my last day as
a visiting researcher,
but it's likely I will come back.
So, if you want to talk to
me then either catch me
right after the talk or later.
This is, in fact, work
that has been done with
many people almost centrally
my student Maciej has
contributed to the development
of the Slim Fly topology that
I will be talking about.
But at the beginning, I want
to give a quick overview
of network topologies,
in general, what
the development was.
But let me start with
a quick statement
about data centers.
Microsoft is operating in
a pretty sizable data
center business,
and it seems to be
moving further into
the central attention of
the company as we
are all observing.
There are some observations we
can make about data centers.
So, first, Google,
some people from
Google, so Dennis Abts,
he actually observed in
this paper down here that
about up to 50 percent of
the energy consumption of
a data center could be somewhat
related to the networking
infrastructure.
So, he saw various components in
the networking infrastructure
and other things.
Furthermore, there
is another work that
actually calculates that
up to 33 percent of
the network- 33 percent of
the data center costs could
be the networking components.
So, this is something we have
to see with a grain
of salt because,
of course, that varies
on the exact setting.
So, I believe there is
a very large spend.
I would say here, it's somewhere
between 20 percent
and this 50 percent,
it feels very high, and
then the 33 percent,
that could also be lower but
it could also be higher.
So, that really depends on
how well your data
center is connected.
But if you look at the past
of these data center networks,
what happened there?
I mean, what happened from
the early 1980s until today?
This is something we built on,
so I want to quickly explain
what was the history here.
In the early days, data center
topologies or, at this time,
computer topologies,
so nobody talked
about data centers
in the early 1980s,
that term wasn't
probably even coined.
These early topologies
were mainly restricted
by the amount of silicon
available on a single chip.
So, what that meant, they had
to have a very small radix.
So, when I draw
these graphs here,
you just read them
like a normal graph,
and every vertex is a
switch in the network,
and every line is a connection,
so a cable in the network.
What we can see here is that for
this particular network topology,
we choose the dimensionality
of the network,
so in this case, it's two.
Then the radix, so the number of
ports per switch we need
to support is four.
All right, so that's
extremely simple.
It's very, very
simple to construct.
This is actually
the main reason why
these networks have
survived for so long.
In fact, if you pump
this up a little bit,
if you go to a three or four
or five-dimensional tori,
you can get a rather
reasonable network,
but, of course, the
radix is growing.
But there are two problems
with this network,
and these are actually
the two fundamental parameters
we care about in networking,
one is the latency and
the other one is the bandwidth.
So, with latency, I really mean
the distance traveling from
one vertex to another.
The maximum distance here
is somehow the Dth root
of the total number of vertices
in the network, so that's bad.
So, it's actually very bad.
The bandwidth is even worse
because you can cut
this network very
easily by removing
links from the network,
so the global bandwidth
I'm talking about here,
that's relatively
bad in this effort.
Nevertheless, since they
are very easy to construct,
many HPC networks,
so high-performance
computing networks,
have used that topology to scale
very far because people
call this network scalable
of this topology because you
can just add more rows and
more columns in
your particular topology,
and if you want to build
a very large computer,
that's a very good thing.
By the way, there is
a fundamental disagreement
between me and
the rest of the world
or the rest of
the networking architects when
we talk about scalability.
I do not consider this
network as scalable.
So, by scalability,
when I say that term,
I mean that the
bandwidth scales and
the latency scales as we add
more vertices to a network.
In this sense, this
network is not scalable.
However, every network architect,
when the network
architect says scalable,
they usually mean, "We can
add more stuff to it and
it's relatively easy to
rewire the network."
In that definition,
it is scalable.
So, what happened
then, well, this was,
of course, discussed
and discovered.
So, then we went to
hypercube style networks
and there the benefit is that we
could actually have
a logarithmic latency,
so that's very good,
and a full bandwidth.
So, now, we have N
divided by two and
we've got rid of
the square root term.
So, we essentially
have enough bandwidth
that half of the nodes can talk
to the other half of
the nodes without
any congestion in the network
and not just the
square root of those.
Of course, the network
radix is not logarithmic,
so that is fundamentally
limiting your size of the
network you could have at
the end because you will
still need to build a switch
with N ports and then you can
only have two to the N endpoints,
and N was very
small at that time.
So, what people developed, well,
the first idea to use were,
well, a brief idea,
were tree networks.
So, people just looked at
trees and this is what
many data centers
still look today,
the kind of the last
generation data centers.
Look, the tree networks.
>> Sorry, even before,
can you just define
what bandwidth,
latency and radix mean in this.
>> Okay, sure. So, you mean here?
>> Yes, or in any
of them because-.
>> So, the latency is really
the maximum distance, actually,
the distance of a
shortest path from
any vertex to any other vertex
in the network.
So, here in this case it's a
log base two N. All right.
So, if you have N vertices,
the maximum distance,
which is the
shortest path between
the maximum separate two
vertices is log base two N.
>> The shortest or the largest?
>> That is the shortest path,
not the longest path.
>> Between any?
>> Between any vertices, right.
Then the bandwidth is really
how much bandwidth
can I carry through
the network in terms
of N. All right.
So, if I'm, for example,
I have a simple
all-to-all pattern everybody
sends to everybody else,
how much bandwidth can the
network accept in that case?
So, you want this to be N, right?
So, and in the previous one,
this was somewhat square root N
to the D, so very little.
We want this to be N and
this is, here in this case,
this is perfect
because we are very
close to N in some way.
The radix is basically your
technology parameter where,
how large of a switch
you need to build in
order to support that
network topology.
>> So, for example, in this case,
is it easy to see why it's log N?
>> This is just a
hypercube, so this is-.
>> Yeah. I guess I don't know
what the switch is here.
>> Well, a switch is a vertex.
>> All right, okay. So, it's like
the number of edges
leaving a vertex?
>> That's the radix, exactly.
>> Okay.
>> As you grow
the hypercube, you will
have more neighbors, I mean,
every dimension you
add to the hypercube,
you will double
the number of neighbors,
and this is where you have
the logarithmic impact here.
Okay, cool. So, and then we have
this tree network and everybody
knows the tree, right?
The bandwidth is one
because we all need to
go through the root,
so that's bad.
The latency is two log N
because we need to
go up and down,
all right, so, because a tree
has logarithmic depth.
The radix is two because we
have only two neighbors.
We should have probably
started with this one from
an educational
perspective because
that's definitely
the easiest one.
However, this is not
how people build
these trees because usually
in a data center context,
we have so-called top-of-the-rack
switches and then we
have backbone switches
in the sense that
the network technology used
for implementing these cables
gets usually beefier towards
the root and has
just a higher bandwidth.
All right, in HPC or actually,
in modern technologies,
we don't really do this
because we want to
have the fastest connection
to the endpoint.
So, if we already take
our fastest connection
to the endpoint,
we don't have anything
else to do to the top,
so we just have that link speed
that we want to get
to the endpoint.
Okay, so under that assumption,
what was developed,
that was actually
developed quite early on,
this is the so-called
Clos network
or fat-tree network there,
not isomorphic but
very, very, very close.
So, we can discuss
the differences,
but they're usually minor.
So, this is a Clos network,
this is a fat-tree network,
this is a folded Clos network,
but they all have
the same principle.
The idea is that they
have a fixed radix
and then they grow multiple
layers with this fixed radix,
which gives us a two log N
latency, right,
and that also gives
us a full bandwidth in
that particular case.
So, that's somewhat
the dream topology.
In fact, this is the topology
that is used for
most of the installations
of large supercomputer
systems today.
It is used in many modern
data centers today as well.
So, that's kind of the
the default topology.
However, in this talk, I will
tell you how to actually
build a topology with
very similar properties
but has half the cost,
because we still
quantify constants.
Asymptotically, this topology is
optimal, if you don't
care about constants.
But, of course, in
real life, if you actually
invest a couple of 100
million into a data center,
then you care about
a constant of two,
I hope, most people do.
Then, there is this fancy,
Kautz topology, that
is, in fact, a graph.
Now, we are going to talk a
little bit more about graphs.
We're abstracting this away
from the actual technology.
Whatever we implement
these switches with and that was
used in the HPC contexts
that is a directed graph.
So, all graphs before were
undirected and directed graphs
so we could kind of
need directed cables.
I've not seen directed cables
before whatever was
constructed for this and it's
technologically feasible
was constructed for
this particular machine,
the ciphertext machine.
Unfortunately, the startup
company went belly up
pretty quickly after
they developed this.
Parts of the reason could be,
that this was an incredibly
complex network to route and
actually to understand
but we will see.
The nice thing here is
that this is actually
hitting a lower bound.
So, this is nearly
strictly optimal.
So, if we go now
from the 1980's to
2005 this is the quick summary
I just gave you.
But at that area and
around that time
two fundamental change has
happened in the
networking business.
So, one fundamental change
is that we went from
copper cables to
fiber enabled cables.
At that time suddenly
fiber became affordable.
It was around for a long time
but it became
a mass market product.
What does fiber change
in the business?
Fiber changes that we actually
can go long distance.
So, suddenly we were not bound
by locality constraints anymore.
These copper cables if
you know there are only
five meters long if you run
them at a high frequency.
The fiber cables
there a kilometer
long and basically you can wire
your datacenter
twice in a row and
still have a single cable
so that's perfectly fine.
That was change number one
we enabled long cables.
Change number two is that we went
from small ratings which is
too high ratings
switches and that's
just simply following
Moore's Law.
We had more transistors
available on
the chip stability
switches and then
we could just build switches
with larger radiuses.
So, we went from
these four ports
switches to today
easily 100 ports switches
on a single chip.
That's extremely important.
Both these developments taken
together lead to
the development of
the dragonfly topology which
there were two competing designs,
I was part of one designs
so one design actually
survived the other one didn't of
course I was betting
on the wrong horse.
So, I was working with IBM and
the so-called parks topology.
Wonderful idea there was
only one machine built
and I'm not allowed
to talk about this.
Has a very one
large-scale machine
builds and I'm not allowed
to talk about this.
However, very similar topology
was used by Cray to
build the Cascade Style,
area style network, that
is where we currently have
the largest installation in
Switzerland with about 5,000 end
nodes running
that particular topology.
The idea here is that we have
groups that are fully connected.
So, we see five groups here,
and then these groups form
so-called super switches
or super groups that
themselves are again
fully connected.
So, it's a two-layer
fully connected network.
Typically, we use
electrical connections
within the group and
optical connections
outside of the group.
That was the idea.
That's the network that came
from engineering constraints
and here we get again an
approximately "Full bandwidth."
So, we're losing a factor of
two here I can talk about
it it's not too bad to lose
this factor of two in fact.
We get a fixed latency
so three to five,
that also means that
our maximum size
of the network is limited.
So, the maximum size of a cascade
system that you can buy from
Cray is about 65,000 nodes
same for the parks topology,
we can't buy more
with those switches.
However, that's enough
for many installations.
There's also a fixed Radix
node that we are talking about.
But now if you take this,
we took all the experience
we made with that topology,
all the other previous
topologists were
designed with technology in mind.
So, we're ingenious engineers
sitting there and trying
to understand how to
use the new technology
constraints in order
to build the next
network topology.
What we did as scientists.
So, I was always working
with engineers because
I really enjoy working
with engineers.
But we have a slightly different
viewpoints so what we did,
is we said, "Okay, let's
take this to the extreme.
Let's just assume we have
an all fiber network because
fiber is relatively cheap
today if you choose
the right transceivers.
Let's assume we want
to build the cheapest
possible network."
What I mean by cheap as we
want to have a full bandwidth.
So, bandwidth of
proportional to N.
We want to have
the lowest possible latency
and the lowest possible
radix at that time.
So, what happened
then, and we use
mathematical optimization
principles to
achieve this so this is
really the key here.
But what we found is that
actually if we drive
this optimization,
all we need to care
about is the diameter.
It took me quite a while
to understand this
but after all it is
really really intuitive.
If you have a network
where you run
your traffic through and you
have basically all to
all communication the further
you go in this network,
the more links you traverse,
the more bandwidth you
need on those links.
If you go very short you need
less bandwidth thus
you need less cables.
That's the intuition
behind this whole idea.
Now the question is. Well,
it's basically written here.
What we found is that in order to
get to the lower bound we
can improve 50 percent over
fat tree and one-third
over dragonfly.
So which means we can
make these topologies at
the same performance
by a factor of two,
less expensive or by
a factor of one-third
less expensive.
So now, let me tell you, yes.
>> The diameter?
>> Oh, the diameter is again,
the path length
so that's between any two
nodes the minimum path.
You want to shrink
the graph as a whole.
Though that's the same ceilings.
>> Oh, it is.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, I actually
confused latency early,
this is interchangeable.
But the idea is that if
you want to make sure that
any node can reach any other
node in the network
with no more in this case
than two or four nodes
or intermediate cables.
That's the key idea and
let me look at an example.
So, we have an example that's
a full bandwidth fat tree.
This is in fact a machine
that has been deployed
in Japan that's
a TSUBAME2.0 machine that's
a three-level fat tree.
So, just another fat tree
we have the switches,
three levels, level one,
level two, and level three.
We have the cabling as
I showed before is I
think 24 or 36 port switches
I'm not so sure.
Half of the cables going down,
half the cables going up
very simple topology.
This is a diameter for topology.
We can create a similar setting
with a diameter two
topology that gives us
50 percent less routers and
30 percent fewer cables
in this particular case.
The cables will be slightly
longer though, but fiber,
the cost of fiber as we will
see in a couple of minutes
is actually not too
much for per meter,
it's a lot per transceiver.
So, you pay a lot overhead
per cable because you
need two transceiver,
but per meter is
relatively cheap.
Okay. So, let me now
explain how we built this.
So, this was just the
motivation so far.
But before we do this, I want to
explain you this Moore Bound.
So, the idea is now, well,
if we now want to minimize
the diameter for
a given switch degree.
So, we have the technology,
we have a switch that
we have constructed.
Let's say that switch
has 15 ports,
and now we want to build
the graph that connects
the maximum number of endpoints,
using let's say diameter
two or diameter
three that can be constructed
with a 15 port switch.
So, there is in
fact an upper bound
that's really easy to prove.
So, I'm going to prove
this upper bound
in the next five minutes
that's called a Moore Bound.
The idea here is in graph
theoretical terms that is
an upper bound on
the number of vertices
in a graph with a given diameter.
So, maximum minimum path
between any two vertices,
maximum minimum length path
and a given radix so
the maximum degree,
but for our purpose we choose
the same degree for every
single vertex so it
is a regular graph.
So, in this Moore bound it
is very easy to construct.
Basically say well, if
we have zero diameter.
Well, then we can reach
exactly one node.
It's pretty clear, if
the degree is k. Well,
how many more nodes can
be reached in one step?
Well, that's obviously one plus
k. If you have
the degree the diameter,
if you allowed the diameter
two we can reach at most,
each of those can reach
at most k plus one
more and so on.
So, now we can easily show
this Moore Bound and it's
really the sum where it ranges
from the k times i equals
zero to D minus one then
k minus one to the i.
So, that's by construction
that's the maximum number
of nodes we can reach.
In fact that is not tight.
The bound is very far from
tight but it is an upper bound.
This is in fact the best
known upper bound for
this graph and looking at
these large graphs is
a very interesting
theoretical construct.
So, you can in fact can you get
your graph named after you.
So, one of the famous graphs that
hits the Moore bound
is the Petersen graph.
The other graph I showed you
the Hoffman Singleton graph.
There's only one other
non-trivial graph I
believe it's 57 vertices
or something but it
has to be checked,
that achieves that Moore
bound that graph
has not been found.
So, if you find it you can
get it named after you.
Their whole there's
actually if you Google for
the degree diameter problem
this is a very
well-known problem in
Wikipedia there's a page with
people's names and their
graph constructions
that hit the upper
bound because people
do- mathematicians have fun with
this they tried to really find
the largest possible graph.
We are not going
to do this because
if you look at this table it is
a double exponential problem
to build these
graphs exhaustively,
and if you look at this we
see that we don't get very far.
So, we use another construction
in order to build our graph.
However, we can proof
for that construction
that it is within 10 percent
of the Moore bound.
So, you can gain at
most 10 percent.
If you've done any engineering
10 percent is in the vice,
so that's- that's fine.
Let me tell you a very high
level picture of how that works,
how we construct such a graph.
And this now involves:
first of all I give you
a high-level picture
and then I'll give you
a little bit more
detailed picture,
because it involved group theory.
So, it's not totally
trivial but it's also
not complicated.
So, we want to build a
graph of diameter two.
Why do we choose diameter two?
Well, first of
all diameter three,
we have done with this
graph I showed you before,
the dragonfly graph or
the PERC's topologies is
a diameter three graph.
Because we have groups
and we have at
most one hop in the group,
at most one intra-group hop,
and at most one hop
in the target group.
So, this is the
diameter three graph,
we have such a construction.
For diameter two it's
more complicated,
because we don't have such a
close to optimal construction.
Diameter one is a useless
graph because diameter of one
means I have a single switch in
the middle that needs to
connect all nodes, right.
So, that's not going to work
because I will not build
a switch for
technology constraints,
not build a single chip switch
with 100,000 end points,
right. That's not
going to happen.
So, how does our
construction look like?
It's based on this mathematical
theory developed
here and they call
them MMS graphs
based on the names,
Mckay, Miller and Siran.
So, we have two
identical groups of
routers that will be
the construction.
So, each of these dark squares
is a router in the
network or a switch,
yet again same terminology.
Then, these switches or
routers form groups.
So, here in this case,
it's a five by five.
So there are five groups of
five nodes each,
in the left side,
and these groups have
identical connections,
and I will explain you
how these connections
come to place in
a couple of minutes.
On the right side, we
have exactly the same but
a different identical connection.
So, we have five groups
each of those is identical,
but they have a different
communication pattern.
And then this is still
the very high level picture.
Then, each of those groups
is connected to the other side,
but it's connected
to all the groups.
As you can see, it feels a
little bit like a dragonfly.
Like I have shown
you before, the 2D,
the two level fully
connected graph.
So, here each of these groups
and the left graph is
connected to all of the groups on
the right side and
vice versa of course.
So, it's a very high connectivity
pattern, okay, good.
So, let me now explain a little
bit more how to, in fact,
build a real network like
this and it starts like
much of a group theory by
selecting a prime number and,
finding a prime power, right.
I see some people smiling
and enjoying group theory.
So, we like it, we
select the prime power.
The nice thing is for computer
scientists or engineers.,
two is a prime number
and any power of
two will work to construct
such a graph, usually like that.
We will not use two as
an example, but fine.
And there's a theorem
that we can show that
any prime power Q can be
decomposed into 4W plus Delta.
So, you have to find
this decomposition,
let us also find,
just believe it, in
case you're not familiar
with that theorem,
it's a very basic theorem.
Let me build a slim fly based on
this prime power Q that we found,
and this Q is exactly here.
So, in this case,
Q equals five, five is
a prime number as we know,
and we get obviously
five by five twice,
so 2Q square many routers
in that network, okay.
So, that's the
graph construction.
And the network radix, you can
compute by using
this Delta from up here.
But, that then again we will
see in a couple of minutes.
Once we have picked
that prime power,
we have to build
so-called finite fields,
and again, if you
like group theory
you will immediately
relate to this.
And the idea of
this finite field,
if Q is prime that's
easiest case.
So, for example in
five we can do this.
The finite field we'll
just have all the elements
from zero to Q minus one.
So zero, one, two, three,
four in this case, okay?
With modular arithmetic modular
five in all these cases, okay.
For example if you look
at this Q equals five,
we get two times
five square routers.
So, that's 50 Network
ratings will be seven,
and so here it is five by five
and the finite field will
go from zero to four.
Very, very, very
simple. Okay cool.
So, now let's
actually look at how
we can label these routers
we will need this later.
So, now we have
these 50 routers here and now
we can arrange them in
a very simple labeling space,
we can first have fully
Q equals five example,
we can name the left graph
zero and the right
graph one, okay.
And then we can of
course introduce
this finite field sub Q times
finite field sub Q, right.
So, we name those guys
five by five and it's
a very simple three-dimensional
naming scheme, okay.
So, is there
a question? All right.
So that's an extremely
simple scheme
that we will get back later too.
But now, once we have
found our prime power,
we have constructed
all finite field,
for each finite field,
we can find
the so-called primitive element
in the finite field.
So, primitive element
is an element in
the finite field that
generates a finite field.
So, that's again a tiny bit
of group theory.
So, what it really does,
is that all non-zero elements of
the finite field can be
constructed by taking
that primitive element
to some power,
modulo the size of
the finite field.
So, we can basically write
everything as this Psi
i to the i, right.
So, in this case for five,
what we can do is we
find this primitive
element equals two.
Now, the typical question
is, how do you
find the primitive element
of a finite field.
Yes, we don't know.
However, there is one,
we know that there is one,
and for all the constructions
that we have done so far,
it's really easy to
find via brute force,
you just try, we
have a small Python script
that finds this.
There are some shortcuts to
finding primitive elements,
but it's not even worth
doing it so we just
brute force the thing,
that's very simple.
And as you can see, because
the finite fields
don't have to get very
large until we reach 200,000
or a million end points
in the network.
So, we don't need
these large finite fields.
You can easily check that
two is a primitive element,
I don't want to do it with
you because you have to check
every single of
those four values here.
For example, if you look at this
two to the four mod five
is basically the same,
and it's one, right.
So, two to the four
16.5 is one, good.
What we do then, and
this is also very
well known in
the field group theory,
we build the set of
even powers and
the set of odd powers.
This is the set of even powers,
this is the set of odd powers.
And again, this is
a very mechanical thing,
you don't need to
understand anything,
you just apply it.
And here, we have these two sets,
x and x primes, again,
the even powers is to the zero,
to the two, and so on,
and then the odd powers.
Again, once we have
these two fields here,
in this case it's one
and four and two and
three, still very simple,
we can use these fields to build
the connections for
these groups, okay?
So, and this is also
a relatively simple rule.
So, we first look at the set of
the odd powers which
build our connections
for sub graph zero,
and the set of
the even powers build
our connections
for sub graph one.
Again, if you go
through the example,
we look at the routers,
we look at one of these column,
and we look at our set,
one and four, and now we connect
all routers that have a vertical
Manhattan distance of
the element in the set.
So, first we look at
one, while we connect
every router that has
a distance one, right.
So it's relatively simple.
And then we look at four.
Well there are only
two routers that have
a distance four,
which are the top and the bottom
one, then we're done.
We do this for all
the groups on the left side,
we apply two three
for all the groups on
the right side and we are done.
This is our intra-group
connection, okay?
And obviously, this is not
a real network we need to connect
the groups among
each other as well.
So, the intra-group connection,
and there we have
a simple linear rule,
the two routers, zero, X,
Y and one M, C are connected,
if and only if Y
equals MX plus C. So,
again a very simple
rule to evaluate,
you can write a very small
script that just builds
these graphs so we have
lots of these scripts.
And if you look at an example,
we take this router
one, zero,zero.
So, here X is zero,
Y is zero and M and
C, is already here,
M and C is zero, but you can
exchange those and that would
connect this router to all
these routers back here, okay?
If you just pick another example,
the one, one, zero router.
So, that guy would connect
to the diagonal of the rhombus.
It becomes an interesting
structure, but,
that's due to these prime
fields, these finite fields.
They make it actually a
quite pretty, in fact,
if you look at
those graphs at the end.
And then, I don't want to
do all examples because
it gets not so pretty if
you plot them on a 2D,
a very small 2D space.
So, it's a very tightly
connected network at the end,
and this construction
guarantees, and so,
I'll get to it in a minute
that we only have
one intermediate hop from
getting from A to B,
right, and this construction
also guarantees,
which is not so easy to show,
that we are within
10% of the lower bound.
And so that can be
proven but that's
nothing for this talk.
So, we need to talk.
>> So, how much is the radix?
>> The radix is this 3Q
minus four over something.
So, that's also related to
the prime power you choose.
Now the questions that we have,
built the network of switches.
We have connected
all the switches,
but of course switches are
useless without servers.
So, how do we now put
these servers into place?
This is a very simple question,
how many endpoints do we
attach to each router?
So, here we have a switch,
we have the cables going into
the network and here we have
the number of endpoints.
So, this is everything up
here is the slim flight topology,
everything down here is just
our use of that topology.
The rule is relatively
simple if we want
full global bandwidth.
So, what is full
global bandwidth mean?
It's basically if you run
an all to all steady state,
which means each of those nodes
or end points down here,
injects packets as fast as
it can into the network,
and addresses those packets to
random end points in the network.
That's the workload we
want to support just
random global all-to-all
communication.
We want to achieve that
each of those endpoints,
can do this at the full line rate
as much as this link supports.
By the way this link
is as fast as
any link in the network.
So, there's a homogeneous
link speed network in this case.
So, all of these guys shoot
as fast as they can to
all other nodes and the rule
is relatively simple,
so here's again the animation
and the rule is
relatively simple.
So, we can compute this I'm
slightly running out of time
so let me just give
you the result,
the ideas and the way
you can derive this
the intuition is
again that we have,
do we have an animation
for this exactly.
So, that we put one-third of
the links from the router
that leave the router
to end points,
and two-thirds to the network.
Why is it two-thirds
to the network?
Well, remember we have
the distance to network.
So, this means these one-third,
they will shoot into the network,
and they will leave,
they will occupy one-third
of the outgoing links,
just by shooting
into the network.
But then there are also
these other nodes that
need to route through
my router because
they have to have
an intermediate hop
and get out again.
This is again
one-third incoming and
one-third outgoing, so
that's the intuition.
If you have a diameter
three network by the way,
this would be one quarter
at the end, and so on.
If you assume uniform
routing and we will get
to the routing we
do actually uniform
load balanced routing
in this network,
okay, does that make sense?
I see people nodding perfect.
So, now let's do
two very simple cost models
and there are two ways to
arrange switches and
endpoints in the network,
so one is to stop of
the rack model that
everybody seems to be using,
so we have our racks here,
there's about a
one meter distance
that gets actually relevant for
the cable length computation so
we have one meter
distance between those,
and we can have
a different network
or differently out but we put
all the switches in the middle
of the data center.
So, the interest which
links will be very short,
but there will be
long wires coming from
the endpoints to the switches.
In fact this is a slightly
better configuration
in most of the cases.
This is slightly easier to
install and maintain because
here the problem is if
you have your large switch
in the middle,
you need to route all cables
somehow through real space into
that middle thing and
they're usually
becomes a total mess.
Well if you do this,
you have a nice distribution of
your cables throughout
the whole data center,
you don't have the one point
of failure also,
so usually people like
this in practice this
looks better in theory.
Okay and now, of course
we have to talk about
the cables at the end if you want
to really define
costs at the end,
so we have a very
simple cable cost model
and here the idea is that we have
a length in meters and
the costs dollar per
gigabyte per second.
Then we look at various cables,
so monologues cables typically
so fiber cables you
can buy on the market,
in fact this number comes
from colfax direct,
so you just look at an online
shop what these cables cost,
so they're not representative
if you buy it at volume.
But I'll be assuming that
they get equally cheaper,
so we're assuming that fiber
cables get equally cheaper
to copper cables if
you buy it in volume.
What we can observe is that,
these are the copper cables you
can already observe they
only go to seven meters.
You cannot buy a copper cable
longer than seven meters.
We still assume you could
write a linear fit.
The fiber cable
start very high so
they're extremely
expensive fossil cables,
because it transceivers
are so expensive,
but the cost per meter,
okay remember length
here is very low.
So, you can go very far,
once you've invested
your transceivers for
the fiber cable and
here the transceiver
is basically free.
So, only the cable costs.
This is the difference
but this is what
we use for the later cost model.
Here we have the exact numbers
here for the two fits.
The router cost model is similar,
because we need to worry
about the different rate
x and the cost dollar
of the router,
here we have some numbers
and we see that
there's also somewhat
the linear relationship between
the radius of the switch
and the cost of the switch,
that was very surprising to me,
I was expecting a more like
a quadratic relationship
because a crossbar full,
bisection crossbar takes
quadratic chip space,
but somehow that turned
out linear in practice.
We used again Mallocks gear just
because we could
get this commodity
off the shelf pricing.
If you now look at these
different topologies
and I don't want to spend
too much time on this,
but the idea here is
we have the number of
end points of this axis so
in thousands up to 50,000
nodes in the network yes.
>> [inaudible] do you also
consider like the cable and cost,
and the maintenance cost,
but a cable goes bad or you admit
a mistaken cable and then
you're rewriting it other side?
>> So, there are
two answers to that.
So, first of all we don't
directly consider it because
it's extremely hard to
assess what that means.
So, my favorite story
here is that,
that I was actually I
was helping to construct
the blue water system
at NCSA which was
the largest academic
supercomputers of
$500 million project at
the time went online 2012,
was the 3D Torus.
You would assume that's
a very simple topology to cable,
and I was helping to
design the network at
that time or helping to also
do performance analysis,
and then I thought, okay
let's actually walk
into the room and cable
one of those racks.
So, I went there, I have
no physical abilities
of my own right but I still
tried to cable one
of those racks,
and it looked like a total mess.
Even for 3D Torus,
what is the reason for this?
Because the 3D torus, you have to
arrange it in a 2D space,
but you also have
to make sure that
these wrap-around links
don't get very long.
So, what you do is you fold it,
and at the end once you've done
all this folding and there's
arranging in the 2D space,
the cabling doesn't look
very regular anymore,
at least not to my limited
ability of assessing it.
So, in fact I would
conjecture that even the
more complicated topology,
would not look much more
complicated if you wire it.
Because at the end what you do,
when you wire these
or what I did,
the particular Cray setup
is you have your table,
your sheet of paper,
that has numbers on it,
and then you take
the number of table
into the number port here,
and then you have to
make sure that it goes
into the other number
port down here.
I would assume we
could do the same,
it's just that
the numbering would be
a different permutation
of those numbers,
so I would not be too
worried about that,
and even though I have
very limited experience
with this I have to say.
The second question
is I'm actually not
a big fan of rewiring.
So, you mentioned what
happens if these cables fail.
Let them fail. So,
we will get to this.
I'm a big fan of
failing place networking
because you cannot
pull the cable anyway,
like if you have cable
like fiber cable lying in
the cable lying enclosure,
and our cable lying
enclosure even for
the blue water system
was like this thick,
and for the park system
that they were planning that
would have been like this.
There was a completely crazy
system and I don't know
100 kilometers of cable or so
was the deal for that system,
but you don't worry about
it, you put them in,
and the idea for
these systems was actually
just throw a new cable
over the old ones.
But, most topologies
actually degrade gracefully.
The torus does not,
but dragonfly does and
slim fly does as we'll
see in a minute.
So, which means if a cable fails
other routing will
fix it, no worries.
As long as not more than 10
percent of your cables fail,
you will not lose
more than 10 percent of
your bandwidth and in fact it
even degrades
gracefully afterwards.
So, if you lose 20 percent
of your cables,
you lose 20 percent eventually.
The question is now, well, when
do these things disconnect?
When do you actually
have a node that you
cannot physically reach anymore
because too many cables failed.
There will be a slide
on this in two minutes.
Let me just finish
the cost argument.
The cost is just purely
the cost of equipment.
The cost of the cables,
as I showed you the cost model
and the switches.
So nothing else.
No installation, nothing.
Here we see, just
to pick out one;
the Fat Tree is here, Slim Fly,
of course, the cheapest one,
Dragonfly slightly
more expensive,
so there is this factor of two,
here, typically, and
a factor of one-third here.
Then, you could look at Torus,
Torus is even more expensive.
But this is something to
look at with more time.
Just believe me, it's the
cheapest network
and the mobile it
will be slightly below here
like 10 percent or so. Okay.
>> Of course, the cables
was proportioned to length.
How you calculate the length
between the nodes.
>> This is why I showed you
the data center layout picture.
So, this guy here.
Yeah, one meter here.
We assume that there is
one meter interact distance.
If you actually
look at this paper,
you get a much more
detailed description of
the enclosure size and
everything, we assume.
So we really model
a full datacenter setting.
That makes it rather
complex in fact
to get all the routings,
and even the layout
is non-trivial,
but that's all
described in the paper.
So, let's just look
at a case study.
Let's assume we want to build
a network with 10,000 endpoints,
which in the Slim Fly would
get us necessary radix of 43,
and would get only 720 switches.
With 10 thousand endpoints, I
find this pretty cool actually,
a very small number of switches.
If you look at this, if you
keep the radix constant,
we could build
these different networks
like Fat Tree, Random topology,
Flat Butterfly, and Dragonfly,
and we would see that they
will all be much more
expensive in terms of power
per node and cost per
node than Slim Fly.
Just look at this,
this is always smaller here.
If you say this is
unfair because we fixed
the radix and we get slightly
different numbers of endpoints,
we can also fix
the number of endpoints
here and have a variable radix.
By the way, all these
other topologies,
we drive into the optimum
for their setting.
So, we say we want to build
the optimal Flat
Butterfly network,
and we just pick
the right radix for this.
If you do this, then again,
we get about 20 percent
cheaper in terms of energy,
and well, 30 percent cheaper with
the best competitor
in terms of cost.
Okay? Very good.
Now this resilience question
that we had on,
like you didn't really
ask that question
but it's related.
Can we just have this
network degrade randomly?
The idea here is we look at
a fully connected network
and we check what happens
if you remove links,
like random. Random links.
A lot of Monte Carlo
simulation studies,
we do this for all these
networks and I don't have
enough time to go
through this because
I'm already slightly over time,
but the percentages
which you see here,
how much percent of
the number of links
you have to remove before
the network becomes disconnected.
Meaning, one node is not
reachable anymore in the network.
You can see with the Fat Tree,
that's about 35
percent for small,
and Torus is really bad as
he goes down if you have
more nodes because it's
really easy to disconnect
one guy in the corner,
while for Random
topologies and Slim Fly,
Random is expected
to be very good,
because cables are just
like Random anyway.
Slim Fly, it's about
as good as Random,
better than Dragonfly and
better than Flat Butterfly.
Very unexpected as well,
so it's one of those results
we were looking at oh.
But actually, it
makes sense graph
theoretically and we can
talk about this offline.
[inaudible] the whole node
goes down [inaudible]
>> No, we didn't do this.
But it behaves similarly,
I would strongly suspect.
So, we didn't look
at node failures,
only at cable failures,
or link failures.
Okay. So, then we could
talk about routing
but let me skip this in
the interest of time because,
again, you can use
the Galois field theory that I
explained earlier, to route.
Now let me get to the last
result I want to show you.
It's a real simulations
for that network.
Did I just say real simulations?
Okay. So, we didn't
actually build
physical network because we
don't have that much money,
but we use the simulator
that was developed
by Professor Delhi and
his students at Stanford.
To show the utility of
the Dragonfly topology,
we took the same simulator
and ported it to Slim Fly,
and here are some
simulation results with
that exact same simulator.
So, it's not our simulator,
that's what I want to say.
It's a real setting.
How does this work?
So, again, slightly if you're not
used to looking at
these networking plots,
let me explain this.
So we have a latency,
this is basically,
we have an all to all pattern,
as I mentioned earlier.
Every node injects packets
into the network that have
a random destination node.
They are routed through
the network according to
the routing strategy that I
will talk about in a minute.
Okay? Well, some we'll
get to their destination.
Here, we say, well,
what if we send
zero packets per second?
That's not close to
zero, of course,
if we send zero, then we get
nothing but close to zero.
Here, what if we send as
fast as the link supports?
So, zero offered load
until one offered load.
Ideally, and
then the latency here.
So what happens, if you
push data into a network,
all of those plots are
very characteristic.
They start at the latency.
This is the lowest,
it's basically your diameter
of the network.
You can see Slim Fly
always best in terms of
latency because the
diameter is lowest.
So, this thing here,
Slim Fly with minimum routing,
this is Slim Fly with
another routing,
this is Fat Tree up here,
and then it's Dragonfly here.
You see Slim Fly diameter two,
Dragonfly diameter three,
Fat Tree diameter four.
So, you can see this
here very clearly.
If you have no loads,
well, the network is empty.
Now, assume if we increase
the load and it's like
a real traffic on a real street.
If we increase the injection
of cars into a network,
remember it's a lossless network,
so like cars packets
don't get lost.
At some point, there
will be a traffic
jam in the network.
Sometime the network will
be just be clocked up.
This is when this
goes to infinity.
So, this means your network
stops, essentially.
All of these go to infinity then,
none of those goes to 100 percent
because routing is not ideal.
What we can see here,
the question is not well,
how does it behave for
this going to infinity?
So, Dragonfly doesn't
fare all that well,
that's because routing is very
complicated on the Dragonfly.
Here, we see Fat Tree
is the best one.
Fat Tree has the latest
going to infinity,
which means it has
the highest bandwidth
but also twice the cost.
But if you see,
this distance here,
it's only like five percent more.
So, once again, one
of those things.
Well, do I want to
pay twice as much for
five percent more
bandwidth? Maybe not.
Then, we have the Slim Fly,
which is here very close and
contender for the Fat Tree.
Okay? So, these are the networks.
Then, I could show
you a large number
of other plots that you
can find in the paper.
I guess that's probably
not appropriate here,
and I want to wrap up briefly
with a couple of
takeaway messages.
So, first takeaway
message is that
we now have the lowest
diameter topology,
in the sense that we
now approach the Moore
bound and it's going
to be very hard,
impossible to improve upon
the cost of this topology.
Because, well,
the theoretical bound,
that we cannot take
make much better,
and it is resilient.
It's very cost and
power effective.
A 25 percent over Dragonfly
and 26 percent in terms of power.
It gives you the lowest latency
because diameter two and
it gives you
a full global bandwidth,
and then we have lots
of results for this.
One last thing I
wanted to mention,
you can actually use
that same topology
to build a network on chip.
It's exactly the same,
very nice properties.
But of course in
a different setting,
we can never go in chips,
it had different parameters,
they don't have fiber
connections, for example.
But we did this, this appeared
this year at [inaudible].
But it's basically
the same construction,
it's slightly different layout
because we need to lay it out in
a 2D book graph style topology,
so limited number of layers,
but this works really,
really well in a network
on chip as well,
and we assume that there are many
different other uses for this.
So, with that, I would
like to thank you for
your attention and I'm
open for questions.
Any questions that
haven't been asked
during the talk? Yes.
>> So, do you have
any intuition while you
are making that graph
using those finite fields.
>> So, yes but it took us a
while to develop
that intuition why we do this.
Eventually, it is really
a graph theoretical problem
that you want to solve.
In the nice pieces
that this problem,
this degree-diameter problem and
you should really Google for it,
it's very interesting for
theoretical mathematicians.
So there has been
quite some work on this.
The idea why we go through
these finite fields or
why they go through
these finite fields,
it's really to build the
graph with the maximum girth.
So the girth is the length of
the shortest length
of the circle.
We want to maximize this
because you want to
distribute data as
much as possible,
as quickly as possible
to as many nodes.
If you have many short circles,
I mean trivial circles,
then this is not
suitable too well.
So, that's my intuition
that I developed over time.
You could also look
at Ramanujan graphs,
and then there are
other graph classes
that don't only work
for the diameter two,
but they're further away
from the Moore bound.
So, for diameter two, we
are very lucky that we have
this one construction
that gets us very,
very close, and for the other
larger diameters we don't.
But for larger diameter, we have
different topologies
that we could use.
So, that base is covered
well. Any other questions?
>> Does the routing needs to
be optimized to know that-?
>> Yes, yes, I skipped
the routing slides,
but you can actually use
the same by construction,
you know where the cables are.
And by construction, you
can find the shortest path,
in this three-dimensional space
that are lined out,
you can find
which node to hop to,
where to go to the final
destination, but that's not all.
Routing is slightly
more complicated.
You cannot really employ
shortest path routing
on this topology.
I had to skip this
for time reasons.
Well, you can. Okay, so
let me be more precise.
You can apply
shortest path routing,
where you just route along
the shortest path which is
always of diameter two, right?
But if you do this,
then I can give you
a traffic pattern
where you will look really bad.
So, I will just choose
some nodes and I will
create a congestion that
is of the order of k. So,
if k is zero degree.
This is very easy to
construct actually,
so it's not too hard.
So, if you don't want to run
into this problem,
what you have to do,
is you have to employ
adaptive routing.
So, you have to somehow check,
well how busy is my next link,
and if that link is
very busy because
already too many endpoints
are sending onto that link,
I'm sending along
a non-minimal path, right?
So, and in the results,
I skipped this for time reasons,
but I can talk a little bit.
So, here we have
different routing,
and this is minimum routing.
This is what I just said,
there's no adaptivity,
and not looking at
the state of the network,
so it's completely oblivious.
Then, we have a valiant routing
which is also oblivious,
but what valiant routing does.,
is it picks a random other node,
we're routing to
this random other node,
and then this random other node
runs to the destination.
It doesn't do too well
because we're losing
half the bandwidth,
you can also see that it's
asymptotically approaching
50 percent because we now
double the path length, okay?
But that's one of these things.
Then, we can use
this UGAL routing,
which was also developed at
Stanford, which gives us,
there are two different variants
here, no actually, this is L,
which gives us
a very good result as well.
And UGAL is now
Uniform Global Adaptive,
and this L is for local.
Uniformly Global Adaptive Load
balanced dash local,
there is a global one as well.
Local only assumes
local knowledge of
the switch, global
is unreasonable,
because it assumes that you know
all the other switches
states in the network
when making a routing decision,
which of course you don't.
But they use this in the thesis
of the student just to
get the upper bound,
I mean what if we would know,
this is why we didn't consider.
So, this is the adaptive
routing that we would
suggest using four Slim Fly.
In fact, a very similar routing
is necessary for Dragonfly,
this is why we only have
one result of Dragonfly
by default uses that loading.
Any of my conjecture would be,
that any low diameter
topology that is
cost-effective will need
adaptive routing, right?
Fat Tree also needs it,
but you can get around it,
most infant event networks,
Fat Tree or route it statically.
>> On the adaptive ones,
do you know,
well this is the closer,
but then this one
is also close or?
>> Yes.
>> You go probably from shortest
to longest in that case.
>> Correct, what
you typically have,
is you have a table,
you look at your output,
your length.
So, you look at what's
the traffic jam into
that direction.
If it's too much, then I have
a secondary and tertiary options
where you just move to next one.
Check if that's too long,
and if that's too
long then I go to
the next one and so on
and thereby distance.
>> [inaudible].
>> Yes.
>> The best part.
>> They're about
five papers how to
optimize this for Slim Fly by
a Spanish group that has
specialized on routing.
So, we have just used
the standard routing,
but they're actually building
a real technology out of this.
It's also not so
trivial because again,
you need to have
all these streaks and
actually get your packets
through the network,
then it's also
virtual channel question.
How many virtual
channels do you need,
that you don't have deadlocks?
This much more complicated than I
could explain in
this 40 minute talk.
But actually, quite
many other groups have
invested really heavily
into making Slim Fly work.
So, we now understand
fully how to build.
So, that's- and there are
at least two companies that
are very seriously looking
into billing at the problem,
as I said, I'm not allowed to
talk about those companies.
But there is very high interest
because we now really
understand it.
If you have a router
for Dragonfly,
which we do, right?
There's a company that built
a router for Dragonfly,
the same router will work
with some minor
modifications for something,
because dragonfly already
needs adaptive routing.
So, Slim Fly play is
not more complicated,
it needs different directions,
but that's all.
Technology is the same.
>> So, how do you use this in
science for building
a quantum computer?
>> Well, now the question is,
how much computes do you actually
need in order to build
a quantum computer?
If you can have that compute on
a single chip, then you
probably don't need it.
But even though the the
on-chip version of
that thing you could need,
because you would still route
among multiple elements.
But, what now, if that
compute, for example,
for quantum error correction,
which can be arbitrarily
expensive, as we know,
depending on what
exact scheme we use,
and then how long
the coherence time should be,
we may need much more
compute than this.
And then, you would
build a larger scale
system out of those guys.
Actually, it doesn't only
get good for larger scale,
it also begins to kick in
with like 40-50 endpoints.
So, for example,
the network on-chip
topology that we designed,
that starts with a design
for 100 tiles on the chip,
and we get best performance
for 1,000, but yes.
>> Also all of the computes.
So, [inaudible].
>> That's what I always
wanted to discuss exactly.
Can you use this for
teleportation networks
or for swap networks?
But there it seems that
these swap networks.
>> I think you need to
be able to talk about.
>> They need physical.
>> Definitely physically-
connected. Yes.
>> Yes, exactly.
>> But unfortunately, this
is not purpose disturbed,
the scaling that our work
commits is intrinsic disturbed.
>> Correct, once we fully
understand what the properties
of attributes are,
then we wish we could look
into this if this makes sense.
I believe this would
actually makes sense because
this graph class is
extremely powerful.
>> Yes.
>> I'm not using the technology,
but just using the graph class,
and applying it to
the same problem.
Yes. I believe that would be
a very good thing to look
into once we understand
the properties.
Cool then. Thank you,